their players on the bench so there  won't be a problem there  Lopez grabbed his headband  took Trent's headband off as he had him  in the clutches  and annoy coming over to help his  teammate right there that looks like  this one is going to be started with  Lopez and the officials were certainly  want to go take a look at this you  really you can't take somebody's  headband off I wouldn't think so that's  for you to take it it started with Trent  holding him but that's a basketball play  and they just missed the call you don't  see Brook Lopez the previous play is  being reviewed for a hostile act a  hostile act so I guess taking the  headband off is a hostile Act